i'm gonna sit down and i'm just gonna
start this episode because i set this
camera up and the first thing graham
says can i look at that angle because it
doesn't look like it's set up right
how can you tell just by looking at the
camera it's closer than usual how many
times jack does alex set up that camera
and the shot's not good
i don't want to get in between you two
what would you ask me like 50 50.
okay so i'll say how many times you set
it up and graham has a problem with that
and that's about 95 percent of the time
how many times do you agree with
majority what
there you go it's like a coin toss it's
like i like to leave enough space on
that camera
to crop in a tiny bit so we can adjust
and post because inevitably one of you
guys always shifts okay it happens and
it's not only you guys jeremy when he
sits there for millennial money same
thing happens so somebody always shifts
and i like to leave just a little bit
more
it looks good what you know it's funny i
remember the time one of the first
podcasts we did
where alex uploaded it and i looked at
the screen and it was like bright yellow
remember that oh yeah yeah yeah we color
graded it it would color great but it
still wasn't no okay that was and we
asked alex like does this look good
you're like it's fine
when so basically he's saying he now
questions your judgment from that one
encounter when was that we are at
jeremy's house playing poker
because okay here's what happened guys
it was the whatever the first uh episode
of the impulsive uh when they went to
brit england was yeah they did it in
true geordie studio and they have like
this very like washed out kind of look
and so you guys were like hey can we do
kind of something similar
so i so i shot in a different profile
picture and i edited it and it looked
very color graded because that's what
you referenced that it
didn't look like that though
what are you trying to do it looks like
honestly i will say i i really liked the
final product i think it looked pretty
good yeah it looked as though we were
under a lizard's heat lamp like that's
what it looks like we practically are
dude graham leaves this room at like 80
degrees okay it gets crazy right now
it's probably like 77 and it's only
gonna get hotter it doesn't get any see
through here but anyway the reason we
started this uh episode here is because
jack and i got into a bit of a scuffle
yes a scuffle uh because of facebook
yeah now we did mark
zuckerberg yeah
we should be posting these episodes
maybe clipped up on facebook fake
facebook is a good platform for video
creators and uh we want to take that
route so i had a guy who's all lined up
ready to go jack says no i've been
talking to this guy for months he's
going to do facebook and he's going to
do snapchat for us i said okay we if we
get it all under one umbrella facebook
and snapchat makes sense okay fine uh
but a week has gone by jack and we're
nowhere closer to getting facebook done
meanwhile i have my guy and i said i
just want to go with my guy he he
matched the offer he's good he'll get on
it tomorrow
what's the hold up jack so in my defense
you initially worked with your guy on
your main channel because you're posting
on facebook and then you ended up
terminating that contract false
i like how he just stopped correcting
balls because i don't need to keep going
on correct
what happened it was through a company
he left that company within a few weeks
of me signing on i kept with that
company for four six months and i
discontinued because i wasn't seeing an
roi
this guy left
this guy comes back and says hey your
page is actually doing really well i
just noticed it i left to do my own
thing would you consider reposting on
facebook i could help you um and so i
went with him directly
there we go i was totally under the
impression that he was working because
graham would say this is the guy that
initially did my stuff i didn't know he
left that company real time yep we do
work on snapchat as well my guy does
both and he can start tomorrow so what's
the hold of jack my main thing is the
guy that i was talking to i've been
talking to for a while yes he was slow
but i knew he also had some internal
issues that he was kind of working out
at the moment but he did tell me the
other people that he works with and
there are some massive creators is it
bad if i say their names maybe i don't
know i think i'm sure it's fine it's
probably fine yeah he does like ksi he
does uh no jumper adam that we had on
here and no jumper was doing like six
figures per month with their podcast on
facebook so i knew that this guy checked
out adam's a cool guy he was basically
you know giving the stamp of approval on
this guy adam from no jumper and i just
figured this guy he's really good yes he
may be slow but i know that the work
that he does is guaranteed effective and
i remember your initial impression of
this guy when he started working with
him i didn't know that he left the
company but it didn't work out that
first time you did it and slowly over
time your videos started to do better
but initially they were really
struggling and that's why i thought you
know we could choose this guy sure he's
a little slower but he has guaranteed
quality and he also does snapchat i
didn't know your guy did snapchat which
we just found out right just found out
real time um so i just figured we go
even if this route is slower we have
basically guaranteed success because of
the big clients you know what i don't
like about this guy is that he's not on
it he's not following up with you he
doesn't want it bad enough where he's
like jack where's the contract we've
this has been going on for months i know
because you ask him every time every
time we come to do this yeah before the
show guys graham's asking yeah so and so
this isn't working i wouldn't go that
far because graham has only really been
pressing this for the past week in few
weeks one of the main delays doing this
was the fact that i i requested a
contract from this guy and he sent it
over to graham and i i checked it out i
like i sent it over and i think i texted
you actually multiple times hey check
out the contract it should be in your
inbox and then you lagged on it and it
ended up taking like weeks until we
finally had we forgot about it and then
we revisited it
i like the scuffle
so he says weeks what did he say he sent
the contract over um i forget what
happened it may have been a week not
weeks
maybe a week but anyway i came back with
some changes we we talked about the
changes we came to an agreement on that
and then
this guy had internal problems i'm sure
it's fine ever since you came back with
the changes has been about it's only
been a week and a half right yeah but
ever since the changes we're like we're
good to go let's just get started on it
right and it's been a week since getting
started on it i agree i think it's
starting to get into that point where
like hey man if you aren't urgent on
this we're gonna go to this other guy my
only logic was initially when you worked
with this guy i thought it was him and
the guys no it was just the guys right
the organization and it wasn't working
out initially but this guy has really
good clients and guaranteed success so i
figured
i like what i've heard from my guy and
he has big clients too but is that he
was the guy who was really making this
happen within the company and he went
off to do his own thing uh i think the
company that i was with was good but
maybe they weren't on it like this guy
is
um
and also he noticed my page got
monetized six months later like after i
cancelled uh the whole contract with
them they never reached back out and
said like hey your page is monetized he
just said um he saw what was oh he saw
the engagement video and said from that
video he went to like look me up on
facebook or something saw the page
noticed it was monetized on his end and
gave me a heads up like hey you should
turn on monetization so my guy's on it
yeah and i think we got to make a
decision and my guy did snapchat let's
just do it let's just say yes to this
guy and get started tomorrow what do you
say jack
i would say
honestly i would say wait until 9am
tomorrow if this guy does not get back
to me with one final thing then i'm fine
going with this guy i think it's already
gone a week i if if if it were up to me
i just said let's go with this guy
my thing is that probably that guy's
really good but he has such big clients
that right now an unmonetized page
starting off from the very beginning is
not a priority for him that makes sense
so my guy he is incentivized to like
build up with the entire brand so it
could be my main channel it could be the
podcast
now now i didn't know he did snapchat
now i want to do snapchat with him yeah
so it would help to have everything
under the umbrella he's also month to
month so if we're not happy with this
guy
we could always change month to month
that's true i'm actually down to get
started month to month should we do it
do we have yes let's get started right
now month to month see what happens
because realistically if this guy
doesn't i mean i texted him he didn't
get back to me
since we're over here we're having our
work meeting and we're filming it and we
like breaking up stuff that jack hasn't
done i figured i'd bring up another
thing uh maybe a year ago oh yeah about
a year ago jack
why are you laughing
stuff that jack hasn't yeah what do you
think i'm gonna bring up that you
haven't done jack that you mentioned
about a year ago got my free stock on
public link down below in the
description yeah you just gotta go to
public.com
oh you mean like how they can follow me
on instagram and alex
underscore photographers nobody wants to
say
no uh about a year ago graham said he
wanted to work on graham stefan and
espanyol
no no no no that was something where i
was like you know what i want to get
started on that that sounds really cool
oh you did yeah yeah but realistically
i've understood that's not that great of
an idea because yeah i figured that
people that speak spanish or live in
other countries that predominantly speak
spanish probably would not
i don't think graham's content would
catch as much because they all have
different rules and regulations in these
countries and sure us does have a pretty
decent amount of spanish-speaking people
i just think it'd be as great of a hit
as something that's entertainment rather
than or sorry yeah entertainment rather
than education what are your thoughts on
that i agree with that okay yeah the
thing is uh
i think 70 of my audience is us-based
and when i'm talking about like a roth
ira or credit cards to get or
you know getting a free stock on public
you can't do that in some other
countries so it doesn't make a lot of
sense i still think there's a market for
that because growing up in a
predominantly hispanic neighborhood
where people don't know about that i
think there needs to be education but i
think that there's a market for a
specific type of person who can speak
fluently in spanish to i agree i agree i
mean if someone yeah if someone wants to
do it i'd be open to it if they do all
the work on their end um i'd be open to
it but i just don't think it's worth uh
worth the time yeah gotcha yeah but you
know what we gotta we got a guest on
here we're gonna bring in macy and stir
up some uh stir up some drama right jack
yep jack's heart is beating now
oh my gosh yeah but you know what hold
that thought because we gotta say a huge
thank you to our sponsor grammarly
working in such a fast-paced environment
like this means it's super important to
always be communicating extremely
concisely effectively and quickly which
is why i am so happy that grammarly our
sponsor reached out to help grimly is an
all-in-one writing tool that helps you
communicate clearly and effectively even
when you're short on time we've been
using grammarly for a while now and it's
saved us countless hours on time that
could be better spent anywhere else like
making more content grammarly is like
having a professional writer looking
through your work 24 7. and their free
version is also amazing because it
protects you from basic spelling grammar
phrasing and punctuation but the real
magic happens when you upgrade to
grammarly premium grammarly premium even
offers clarity focused full sentence
rewrites to help you clearly convey your
message and avoid miscommunication
grammarly even has a built-in tone
detector that could help you sound as
confident professional or as formal as
you need so get to the point faster and
accomplish more with grammarly today by
going to grammarly.com
iced coffee or using the link down below
in the description and when you're ready
to upgrade from your free account to a
premium account you can get 20 off when
you use our link down below in the
description once again guys that's 20
off g-r-a-m-m-a-r-l-y.com
iced coffee thank you so much grammarly
and back to the podcast i already wanted
to chime in on the last thing uh
speaking for like the other countries
thing we were just in canada and a lot
of people were like oh yeah we kind of
know who you are but we don't watch you
because it's not applicable because the
laws are different even in canada
yeah it was atrocious i went out in
public and atrocious barely got ranked
holy cow barely atrocious atrocious it
was devastating that isn't it
we got to build our audience in canada
more yeah
that was unacceptable in canada we were
like yeah we pretty much only watch when
you talk about like bitcoin because
nothing else really applies that's true
actually
yeah bitcoin content could be universal
that's true good point but a lot of the
investing even with real estate in
canada the whole structure is a lot
different spanish bitcoin
channel i'm happy with that i mean they
have to be pretty quick on it though
because some of the bitcoin videos are
so like urgent
the turnover would have to be like 24
hours because afterwards the price is
going to be totally different all right
well i don't think we brought you on
here to talk about bitcoin we brought
you on here because you guys recently
went on a vacation and i know that's
something that you want to do quite
often but graham's pretty apprehensive
when it comes to vacationing because he
thinks we should buckle down and focus
on the business now what do you guys
think about that is that a soft spot
within the relationship not trying to
stir up anything
first
soft spot like like
that's not really that wouldn't be a
soft spot that wouldn't be a soft spot
that would be a point
what do you think mace you first well i
mean you know i get really stressed out
like i will keep over committing myself
to things and i get really stressed out
so i don't think that's my place to say
like we should be traveling all the time
i do want to start traveling a little
bit more but like
you even know for canada i was getting
myself super stressed out because i was
throwing around my streaming schedule
then it's just like i mean like that was
tricky for me and to try to keep my
stress levels down i was trying really
hard yeah macy met my uh canadian family
for the first time ever how was that
yeah do they do they have accents no i
think they do drink a lot of fear it's
certain words like certain words some
people like oh you can't tell until you
say about because
i feel like you have to do that with
your face too to go
yeah a boot and like it is about
i'm like oh yeah when you get glorious
singers and they sing
in english they always say about
or out so i'm like why do you why when
you don't think i mean people copy
accents and music all the time so yeah
but yeah so you don't want a vacation
right i'm good on vacations for right
now yeah
what was that three days uh four
actually oh that was a full four day
vacation two full days of travel yeah
and
yeah the traffic you wanna know the
funny part graham and i worked ahead uh
so that he can go on vacation and we got
probably like four videos ahead and
graham leaves on friday which he used
one of the videos that we posted but
then on monday it was the fourth of july
so he didn't post so we got ahead and we
didn't need to get ahead and now we're
ahead and graham prefers it that way
yeah now i want to stay ahead i actually
got a video uh
filmed today so i could continue staying
the same length ahead and i want to keep
that like buffer it feels so relaxing to
know i have like four videos done
feels so good so now that we've talked
about points of contention
let's talk about points of the opposite
of that okay now we're gonna yeah
now regarding yeah i guess i guess
uncontention is that even a word i don't
know no it's not but that's
funny contention
points of love okay so contention
contention already is a negative so i
guess to be attention
uncontention
uncontentious
uncontentioned yeah so between you two
because i know something recently just
happened the proposal we haven't brought
you one and discussed it yet i'm getting
so confused about it because we've
talked about it on so many things at
this point i know graham was like i
thought we talked about it on your
channel yes it was it was my channel but
i thought we did it here too
but
i just have to know so confused did you
cry
yeah yeah i did
yeah after like we were getting off the
the ferris wheel like is my mascara
running and he's like no you're fine but
uh yeah a little bit like i didn't like
like
or anything like that but yeah out loud
crying yeah i think is the video that we
did together we were talking about this
and i think we somehow made that noise
she went nuts she was like trying to put
her snoot in
graham's mouth yeah you do that she'll
go just get like right in your face
she'll want to put her face in your
mouth
all right so so you cried
and were you surprised or did you expect
it to happen i mean like because we
discussed doing our prenup first
definitely i knew it was coming at some
point because we had gotten our prenup
done so i'm like all right this is kind
of an expensive process he's not gonna
just do it and be like i'm gonna break
up with her in like two months from now
or you know i'm gonna do this but i
don't see any kind of a future with her
sort of thing um so i was expecting that
it was gonna happen like sometime
but um
i don't know i don't know how to explain
this properly it's like
you know how
in the spring you're like oh you know it
can rain in the spring
but it can also rain in fall on the
random fall day so i felt like
we'd look in the spring be like there's
a higher chance of rain on any day
during the spring i kind of felt that
way about our anniversary and like
there's probably a higher chance he
would do it on our anniversary but i
don't necessarily mean
or think that he's going to do it on
this day and just recognize that there
was a chance
more than like a random tuesday while
we're sitting at home looking like
little trash pandas all right that makes
sense
what else do you want to know jack back
to points of contention so what is your
no okay uh actually maybe not i actually
kind of want to know i think it's kind
of funny
uh what is
one thing you like about each other and
what's one thing you guys think the
other person can work on
oh
[Music]
jack what are you trying to do here are
you trying to stir up some stuff i just
think the drama people like it i like it
i'll go i could go you want me to go
first yeah i like engage
yeah i like how caring and selfless may
see it she'll put she'll put so many
people before herself she really cares
about the other person really deeply and
i think that's a really important
quality that is is really
comforting and really nice i and yeah i
agree with that i came over here for
graham's pool day and i forgot a towel
and i requested a cow from graham and
graham was like you forgot to tell oh
jack come on making a huge deal because
i forgot a towel
and then i asked macy i told you i said
hey i used to tell and you're like oh
that's totally fine just toss it in here
i'll just do it with my next load it'll
be no big deal seriously whenever you
need a towel just take one of ours it's
totally fine
so i agree yeah she's definitely she's
very sharing and compassionate yeah you
know what cracks me up about the towels
too i have bought in every single one of
those pool towels in there and you're
like yeah
i'm very very
so i'm surprised you guys are gonna use
all 30 towels
well it's nice to have them you never
know i bought that many towels that way
if someone came over they could just
grab a towel and use it i don't know i i
think we gotta use them sparingly that's
yeah right it was put on my credit card
i don't care
it's like i i do all the laundry i pay
for the detergent like i don't care well
thank you and when i should tell like
what's that gonna do to my load of
laundry really even like five
thank you macy i appreciate that yeah
graham now you go one thing you think
she can work on maybe uh i would say
uh
i would
sometimes the organization
there there's
things that maybe are on the floor for a
little bit too long
uh things that could be put away it's
odd because some areas like the laundry
room i've never seen a room more
organized than that like
everything is labeled pantry
yes in the beginning of the pantry but
we've all kind of like had our fair
share with the pantry so it's like it's
not going to stay like that forever uh
but then other means you know
it could be just you know
tidy but i'm not i'm not perfect either
i i'm not you know a saint when it comes
to that but i will go through every now
and then just like i habitually like
every time macy leaves she'll come back
and like every everything is like made
and tidied up and i just i get on a
cleaning spree all right macy it's your
turn what's one thing you like about
graham and one thing you don't like with
graham i really like how passionate he
is about things he has so many interests
and so many things he's really
passionate about and it's really
inspiring to be around like just as a
person when graham's into something he's
in like a hundred percent and that was
something like even link with our
relationship was really cool to see in
the beginning he was just like
this is my girlfriend we had been like
we'd gone on like four dates
at this point and you were like we're
filming a video for my second channel
together for the algorithm yeah and like
he's really into
but like even like with how he is about
youtube the fish tank just
you know anything he's passionate about
he's a very busy person but he will find
the time for and i think that's
something that's just super inspiring
and something super cool and something
that's honestly like one of my favorite
things about him um
things i don't like
i think sometimes which is so funny
because i'm like it's
not meaning for this to be on the same
vein as what you said sometimes i think
you your brain you get caught up in
things and then you just don't have any
kind of an organization system or you
can't follow an organization system and
it drives you nuts oh this is me putting
things in the wrong drawers that's what
this is about probably like um like
and the rare occasion you unload the
dishwasher he'll like put all the forks
and spoons and the same thing even
though we have like all the
organizations like sometimes the big
spoons end up in like here and then over
here oh it's just different little
things like that i feel like i'm always
kind of fixing
where i'm like
where where's the the thinking in this
no there's some of them i don't i've
never seen this thing before and i've
just like put it in a drawer i've never
seen it before yeah it's some random
cooking stuff i've never i've never seen
it before
that's very descriptive i know i don't
know it's like it's like a strainer of
some sort or like some contraption i
don't know
see he'll say that and be like i've
never seen it and then he'll go and
he'll make himself pasta while i'm gone
he knows where to find it
oh yeah i don't know i don't know
they'll be like man where did this end
up over here why is this here and i
don't know it's just this it's there at
this point though i'm like somebody is
doing this because this is a constant
battle i have with the kitchen i know
sometimes it's like the cleaners
sometimes but like there's stuff i find
sometimes i know it's you sometimes i
don't know who it is blame it on alex
it's probably alex i found a knife one
time in one of my pots and pans graham i
don't know i don't i i don't know who
did it graham doesn't even know what a
knife is i don't even use knives don't
really use a fork for everything
basically same yeah that is crazy person
talk so you're telling me if you had
something that needs to be cut like a
potato or a steak
you know what i do actually as i stab it
as i stab it i just eat it like a
popsicle
it's like bite off it like a chicken
breast will stab like this that's
actually what kelsey does yeah um but i
have a better system i use a fork but
then i use the fork sideways to cut
things oh i've done that too yeah but
only if it's like cuttable that way
though chicken can be fish could be but
not steak you're a cave
i man eat with my fingers i would
honestly i'm i'm 100 with you on that
but i know it's not a sight other people
probably enjoy seeing as if i'm like
mangling yeah yeah i mean i'm fine with
graham like when it's just him and i but
when other people i'm here like okay
stop doing that or like if we're out at
a restaurant i'm like
okay like we can be uncivilized at home
and i use the fork to pick my teeth
afterwards do you really no i'm kidding
no he just gets in there with his
fingers yeah yeah it's super deep in
there yeah that one long nail that sees
everything alex i have to have a little
moment in brag so switch back to your
camera
i figured out how to get that to
disappear on my camera and it took me
like five minutes
no no i know how to make it disappear oh
i was so excited no you want that to
stay here yeah that's on purpose yeah i
hooked up my streaming set to my camera
so yeah pretty good yeah like that
else you want to know well to be honest
i i don't want to cena's i don't want to
be seen as that guy who just like
instigates things you know what i mean
and creates drama out of nothing but
you know since you're asking me um it
just seems like you guys went a little
easy on each other or if you didn't go
easy on each other your guys's
relationship must be
perfect and i'm not saying it's not
perfect because perfection can still
have flaws but it's gotten good it's
gotten really good oh it's gone so where
were we before
i think at the beginning of our
relationship just there was a lot of
adjustments both of us had to make and
we learned how to make them together and
so i feel like we've really worked on a
relationship together like we didn't
have this perfect relationship from the
beginning but like there was no one else
i'd rather work on on it and i admit i'm
not an easy person to both live with or
even work with like i i understand uh
that's that's you guys have to put up
with a lot and i'm not always simple so
uh i feel like this is like am i
supposed to be like no no no no you guys
could chime in like i i i
don't think i work that well with other
people
really
i would say select i would say select
people
yeah graham is literally like the human
embodiment of a cat and i think i am
more of the human embodiment of a dog
you are so it was yeah so it was
definitely an adjustment you definitely
very much liked your alone time and
because i was so used to having like
you know i was one of three and there
was always somebody home and stuff and
always having somebody around something
i'm constantly interacting with that was
like a big thing for us to work on
because i
wanted like hanging out constantly and
you were
like i will see you on the weekends even
though we live in the same house yeah
yeah for me because i've always just
like i've loved my alone time and like
just i love getting home and just like
peace just it's space it's just like
mentally i need that sort of like
calmness
to like to think and to get through the
thoughts and so like but i think that
was a big adjustment yeah i think it's
hard for people that don't spend a lot
of time with you people that just see
you on occasion to understand that
that's who you truly are yeah and not
that you're just some standoffish person
who like doesn't care about them or
interact with them right that's just who
you truly are you enjoy being by
yourself it's not like you don't like
them that's why you're not talking with
them yeah so i think that's something
that is hard for people that don't truly
know you to understand and also it's
funny you mentioned that you're hard to
work with and i remember in the
beginning it was a lot more challenging
but now since i know you very well
i'm able to
to definitely change the way that like i
talk to you to be in an engaging way for
graeme
i try to condense the information that
i'm telling you into the fewest amount
of words possible yeah because if you
drone with graham at all tunes out
immediately tunes out
yeah no i i've learned and the longer
we've been together the more blood
they've been i'm like
he'll you know he'll you'll see his mind
go and grab someone that like as soon as
his brain goes this is what he looks
like
it's pretty much oh my god that's so
active but you also notice graham will
start going he'll start going yeah yeah
yep
and it just starts agreeing with
everything that you're saying like you
could say anything it'll be like yep
grandma i'm gone for two years i'm going
to thailand yep okay all right
so so what i've started doing
is the longer we've gotten together the
more blunt we've gotten i'm like so yeah
by the way you know i'm pregnant yeah it
it's not yours and he'll be like yep yep
well but because then i know she's
joking and i'm like what did i just say
and then he's like
no but sometimes it'll be like you're a
friend and i'm like no no there's been a
few times you've been like and i'm like
and also another thing is you're
extremely blunt to a point where i'm
like i it really surprises me because
you call yourself a person who is not
confrontational but at the same time
you're very comfortable saying you do
not like something for example like the
alex will work hours on the thumbnail
he'll present it to you and you'll be
like nope or all with the patreon like i
drafted up the entire thing i designed
it and i was like and for some reason
that was already my responsibility and i
went in i did all the work and
everything i presented it to you like i
don't like that i don't like that change
that change that moment graham you gave
me the authority to make these decisions
in the first place and it it's fine i
totally get it but it's something that i
have to understand when i start doing
stuff like that korean's gotten worse at
this i would say because of because of
me because that's how i am i'm pretty
stupid you're both very very particular
and very uh blunt
things i i like to say i'm like nice
blunt but yeah if somebody does
something that i
have no issues with confrontation
but i think i like like normal normal
levels of issues i won't like go out of
my way and avoid confrontation but if
graham's like zoning out i'll be like
hey are you i'll like put my hand
between him and the phone i'm like i
feel like you're not listening to me
when you're on your phone he's like oh
yeah i'm not
but at the end of the day i think that
that's
a heck of a lot better than not being
blunt blunt and like hiding how you feel
and i honestly i really admire it and
that's something that i definitely try
to do in my own life because if i'm
gonna act like i like something to
something to someone who's telling me
something i clearly don't i think we're
just going nowhere with that
conversation because we're not we're not
you know what i mean i'm not being
honest with my intention she's not being
honest you know i mean yeah and there's
no progression so i think it's i think
it's a great way to communicate i
respect it yeah i'm not like one of
those like oh you know i'm not me and
i'm just blunt type of girls out there i
think i'm definitely one of the nice
ones because like if somebody came to me
with like a thumbnail like that it'd be
like you know i can tell how much work
you put on it i do like the compliment
sandwich you know yeah but like you tell
how much work you put on it but i don't
really like this aspect can you change
it but like you know you worked really
hard on this and i can tell you're
getting better and i always kind of do
the like blunt yeah graham is just and
i'll find like
no carbs
no carbs i'll find like two things i
like with it and then the one i dislike
and usually that is true with most
things it's like there's not like
there's not something that somebody will
come with to me and be like oh you know
i hate this whole absolute thing so i
try to point out the things that i like
when yeah and i'm like there we go it's
a blunt assessment because i'm bluntly
telling you what i like and also what i
don't like and that i don't know i think
that's what's made me such a good like
personal trainer with people too
is like when you know i had i had a
client who just
who was able to do a pull-up and then
she's like how was that i'm like you
know what you started off you couldn't
even get your arms to contract so that's
amazing that you're able to do it just
next time try holding you know try
holding your body a little bit more
still your legs are wiggling it's
probably making a little bit more
difficult have you seen people when
they're really straining they're kind of
kicking their legs and stuff to get them
i see graham do that all the time
he almost flies
like a helicopter
yeah a little bit so i'll just like you
know
try not doing that might make it a
little easier because you're probably
strange i feel like a lot of the times
it's harder when your legs are kicking
all over the place because in your arms
you're trying to figure out how to
stabilize for very rapid movement um and
let you know and then end off with like
but i'm so proud of you like getting a
pull-up's really hard and so that i feel
like is what's made because it's like
you leave them feeling good
but also with like it's the compliment
sandwich yeah and i really love using
the compliment sandwich and like i'm
really careful with it too not to say
anything that i don't believe like i
won't just like throw out a compliment
that i'm like
i don't believe this at all like i will
say genuinely like that's amazing you
were able to get a pull-up and you know
we got it in like
a month
it's incredible that is so fast but i
won't like sit there and like hype
somebody up on that or give them
compliments if i don't truly believe
them either
you guys are gonna have to teach me how
to do a compliment sandwich in real life
because um yes i'm blunt at work but i
work with graham and jack so it works
but i think i'm too blunt in real life
so i don't think so at all
maybe not never you know like here's
what happens and let me explain so uh
let's take my like mother-in-law for
example um she'll say i think you need
or i think that
you should do x and i'll be like i think
that's stupid
like what give us an example okay just
like not being nice
that's being like what did she
because you're around us all the time
that's just the way you we all
communicate you'll be like do you think
this is stupid i'll think yeah yeah i
don't know
what she asked okay okay no no so i
think i might have mentioned this before
um she asked you to put on hand
sanitizer
guys oh my god
so uh like for example one she she
wanted her
uh her best friend's husband to like
mary kelsey and i and i and i i didn't
say it was stupid i said
i think he's a little weird
you know what that's fine i'm gonna sit
here as the annoying fiancee here and
say it's your dang wedding
who you want to officiate it officiate
it okay i mean i agree you should let
your whoever you want to officiate
officiate it but at the same time i
wouldn't just say
what's their relation to the stepmom or
the mother-in-law it's just her best
friend's husband it's like so that's
someone who she obviously probably
thinks pretty fondly of and i definitely
wouldn't just say i think that they're
weird because
i just think that's like feel like
you're attacking this person okay okay
so let me give you a different example
so like
um
a family member recently bought a house
right and like my first instinct is like
like how much you pay for it and like
i get these weird looks like i shouldn't
be asking this i'm like oh how much you
buy from oh yeah you overpaid big time
well like i don't know how do you do
well maybe how do you deal with that
grandma
you feel out this tweet you don't know
like how much
but that's what i'm trying to say like i
i sometimes i feel like i don't have a
filter and i don't think yeah but you
could pry you could just say like uh you
know were there a lot of offer no you
could say like were there a lot of
offers like i would like did you have to
pay over asking on it honestly i would
just check zillow that's what i would've
known what's the address zestimate comes
in
[Laughter]
is this accurate
sometimes if i catch myself doing that
because i'm around these two so much and
all the finance guys is that if i say
that to someone i can see they're
uncomfortable be like oh you know i'm so
sorry uh
i work with like a lot of people in the
finance industry and they just kind of
ask and i'm sorry if that made you
uncomfortable kind of like oh
just because i'm curious working around
people who are in the finance industry
and usually like when you say that then
people are like oh okay
yeah i would say most of the times it's
pretty excusable i don't think that
you're the type of person that can mess
up so horribly that you actually destroy
a relationship so jack by the way before
i forget i wanted to ask you this
would you be willing
to
become what it takes to
officiate a wedding yes yes yes yes i
was actually just going to bring that
out to you are you actually just waiting
for yeah graham was going to ask that
yeah because macy brought it up i was
like that's a funny idea
i was like either jack has to be the
ring bearer
or he has to be the first i call him
ring bear yeah he could be the ring
bearer but we were going to think
anthony too
anthony would be phone but but
around for so much for both of us that
it just kind of makes sense i also knew
both of you guys before the relationship
even started you would do you're
actually there you're probably the only
person that can say that yeah all right
i'm good with that it'll be funny let's
go i would love to all right all right
oh my god you got to get a haircut
though well i don't know about that
what does the bride say do you think i
should get a haircut i just do your hair
i don't mind it long i just think
see that doesn't that
can switch the camera
that like you have hat hair all right
that looks bad it does i'll agree with
you on that yeah just as long as you do
it just kidding
it works yeah i'm like i'd be lucky if i
look like him all right so jack speaking
of weddings uh i got to bring this up
because i think it's a highly requested
topic and i figured i'd bring it up on
the podcast we should have another first
date on the podcast here as a midweek
you know it doesn't have to be you know
full thing but having a first date you
know and uh just seeing how it goes what
are your thoughts
okay so we've done two things similar to
this before we had a girl on that was
supposed to be my date and we also did a
quadruple me like blind dating for women
okay
and both of them ended up with all the
people in the comment section she's like
what's going on with this girl how is
she what's up with her and i feel like
that's not necessarily like
i just don't like answering those
questions you know what i mean because
most of the time it doesn't go anywhere
i just don't like answering those
questions i'm going to make a i want
walked 100 miles for a tinder date oh
yes explain that jack
oh yeah that's a good point well
honestly most of that was the fact that
i wanted to walk 100 miles but if i was
going to attach to a piece of content it
had to be towards a tinder date and i
feel like that we have so many other
good potential guests opportunities
rather than a girl that's coming on here
for a date plus my channel would get
like 10 000 views the iced coffee will
get more hopefully so
i don't know i just don't like answering
those questions we should let's say you
don't get those questions would you do
it what if we did if if i could
basically snap all of like the
tangential um
effects of a girl coming on here i would
do it yes i just don't like it if i do
meet a girl in real life and she looks
me up or i am talking to someone on
bumble and she looks me up you know what
i mean i think it's actually that she
sees that i i have it's a for content
it's just it's we make it clear from the
beginning it's just for fun i think jack
needs to date like another content
creator i think that would be right it
would work really well i agree with that
alex you know what let's talk about your
weight loss journey how's that going so
far yeah of course so uh if you guys
didn't know i'm on a weight loss journey
jack is helping me out and we started uh
jack how long has it been i actually
don't probably not three three three and
a half four weeks all right so the first
two weeks absolute hell um but now we're
rocking and rolling i feel very
sustainable sending jack pictures of my
food and i have a couple of things that
you know i kind of fall back to make so
one of the things in the morning i like
to make is like a spinach and turkey
omelet um that's kind of one of my
go-to's and i've been just alternating
dinners um and
yeah what what questions do you have so
the main thing is i remember we went and
got sushi this was probably like two
weeks ago and you kind of were
disagreeing with alex's weight loss
methods and i've faced a lot of people
that are saying you shouldn't be doing
this uh jack or this bad advice and and
i've never proclaimed to be like a
nutritionist expert whatsoever but i do
like to think that whatever alex is
doing currently is probably better than
what he was doing previously with like
the the snacking and everything like
that so i want to know what your
perspective is on this as someone who
knows a december about it so my whole
issue was that you put him on calories
based off of where his maintenance
calories were not knowing what he was
already eating you don't want to like
cut someone's calories like let's say
even he's eating double what he should
be you don't want to cut out half of
what someone's eating down to where they
should be at you want to slowly work
them down
not necessarily do a big cup my whole
issue was you don't really know what you
should be doing diet wise for him
because you have no idea where he was
starting why you should have had him
tracking why do you do four days why is
that bad so that's bad because it can
put your body into survival mode if you
cut out too many calories too quickly
this is an issue you see like it's
really like unfortunate obviously i'm
not a doctor when i'm speaking about
this but um
you see this a lot with people who
struggle with eating disorders is that
they'll gain a lot of weight back really
fast because their body when they start
eating again because their body all of a
sudden is like oh we have stuff and like
it'll hold on to um
it'll hoard it yeah it'll hoard it
that's that's exactly the word i was
looking for um there's also that and you
don't want to mess up your metabolism
like messing up your metabolism is awful
trying to fix that is a mess and so you
just want to make sure you're keeping
the metabolism up one of the ways to do
that is working out so always in
addition to nutrition i think you should
be exercising i get like if somebody's
starting a new nutrition plan and an
exercise plan if they know themselves
they know that they have a hard time
sticking to it you definitely
i get not starting both at first i think
that was why you wanted to kind of
wait with alex and i i get that
mentality i think he has at the point
though where he's been consistent with
it for three four weeks now that he
could start working out but yeah it's
mainly just you don't want to mess up
metabolism and you don't want to put
your body into it wouldn't that
eventually just balance out like let's
say initially it's a shock it goes into
survival mode but then if he's doing it
for like a month then wouldn't that just
like set the bar then
you don't really know but it's it's just
dangerous and you don't know exactly how
your body's going to respond to it
so just
it's hard because even if you go off of
his maintenance calories when i jump on
a scale my maintenance calories don't
really account for everything i do it's
like i have a scale that tells me where
my maintenance calories are at but cool
i'm working out like hours and hours a
week and that's more calories on top of
that that i'm burning so you could also
be putting him into a really really deep
deficit
right so my whole logic is we knew alex
was fairly sedentary outside of like you
know yeah coming here and whatnot um and
i just figured
although everyone has all these
scientific methods and all these ways
you can get someone to lose weight and
do it safely and whatnot i figure
anything
that we're trying to do now is going to
be better than what he was doing
previously because he was telling me
that like sometimes he would go and he
would sit with like a huge bag of chips
not the fun size and he would eat like
half of it and that's probably like
that's there's no nutritional value sure
it's a lot of calories and i understand
like setting off your metabolic rate or
metabolism or whatever by like
decreasing the calories i still think
it's better just to eat clean foods to
the point of being full
and
you'll be okay the problem with clean
foods is like a banana is not even 100
calories so i can eat a whole banana and
be full but it's not really if i have
only 100 calories
in the morning i'm not eating what i
need to for the day but if you eat until
you're ready for full wouldn't that jet
generally kind of average out healthier
foods make you feel full faster
so you end up cutting calories down
really fast
just by eating cleaner that was
something that before i started doing
all this and like i did a contest at my
gym and worked with the nutritionist and
everything we looked at what i was
eating and i was severely under eating
because i was thinking oh well i'm full
because i was eating a lot healthier
but did it lead to any actual impact
i wasn't able to gain muscle mass
and it was very fatigued
and i had to take iron supplements so
that that was my like i didn't mess up
my metabolism thank goodness but like i
couldn't also build the muscle like i
was wanting to because i wasn't giving
my body enough to be able to build
muscle and repair properly so i was
getting fatigued for a lot longer i was
yeah just
it wasn't it wasn't fun
definitely then when they put me on they
had me track and they were like you're
way it's just tracking for three days
it's not like he is 600 pounds and
they're worried about like
organs shutting down or like he's not
having the same issues that tammy from
my 600 pound life is having where she
was just hospitalized because the lung
collapsed uh so it wouldn't have been
really that much different to have him
track for three days and see what he's
doing and then just cut him down why not
gastric bypass
seems like that's almost like a sure
thing like i don't know anybody who's
gotten that surgery is that the one
where they make your stomach smaller
yeah but then wouldn't that just put you
in a severe caloric deficit and mess up
your metabolism
yeah i don't know but it seems like
everyone's i don't know what people tend
to say graham is that
you you should try everything
before yeah sure that's true
um i've never personally looked into it
um but i know that that can also
change like how and what you eat for the
rest of your life i believe yes yes yeah
it's kind of like the nuclear option
in terms of weight loss and then also
too because you go into such a bad
caloric deficit you also have issues
like having loose skin because you're
not losing the weight slowly so a lot of
these people don't have to get other
cosmetic surgeries because then they end
up with i think regardless i will
probably end up having loose skin if i
do end up losing that much weight um
just because of the size that i am now
and
something that i've talked to graham and
jack about but not a lot of people know
and this is kind of what has helped me
stay like really focused um i really
want to do things that
i cannot do now like i can't walk into
macy's or h m and go and expect them to
have my size like that's just not a
thing or
like one of my biggest things that i
told drag is like i want to
get a pilot's license right i want to
learn how to fly plane
which when you start off flying planes
they're generally pretty small so
there's just like tons of stuff that i
want to do that uh you know
i i
definitely am i'm like hoping that you
know i i think so far i've created
a routine that is a lifestyle change
that i could sustain for the rest of my
life um but um i've never thought about
gastric bypass before so yeah that's
interesting just they kind of say it's
like the last because like there are you
could mess up your metabolism like the
risks are higher
and then also a lot of these people will
just go back to eating the same diet
that they did before if that makes sense
a lot of them will go back and then it
there are issues i have seen it where
people have gotten it and then they need
to get a second one because they end up
just kind of eating and getting
themselves back to that point versus
like the mentality shift of like i'm
gonna start working out i'm gonna start
doing eating better and different little
things i think that's also why a lot of
the doctors have the patients lose like
30 pounds you know or whatever before um
to kind of show that they're dedicated
towards
losing the weight
yeah i have heard that something that
they've started doing now because it was
it has been an issue with that with
gastric bypass that a lot of people end
up back there and i have heard that now
doctors are kind of like you're gonna
have to lose 30 pounds on your own
without this
um but
yeah it's just that it can cause more
loose skin i mean you could still end up
with loose skin afterwards that would
need to be fixed but it can
end up being not as bad
as if like gastric bypass all right so
yeah one more question i think it's kind
of a we asked this maybe a year and a
half ago i would know everybody in this
room their biggest insecurities you
first jack
me first i gotta think of something sure
my biggest insecurity i've gone on the
record and said it body hair still yep
nothing
okay how about you can't mention the
thing that you mentioned before
i mentioned body hair i mentioned
asymmetrical face i hate my stomach
i hate it
and uh i gotta work harder to get rid of
the the
line of fat like around the midsection i
can't stand it i hate looking at myself
in the mirror because of because of that
did you feel really insecure during the
michael reeves fight about that um
no because actually the uh the the
waistband went above that so it made me
kind of feel better about it so you're
talking about like love handles
like the lowest yeah it's it's
called kind of it's just like around the
bottom it's like like a
little tube
tube
i hate it and part and part of me keeps
thinking like okay when i scale back on
like making videos as much i want to get
like uh like a really strict routine at
least that's something you can just like
yeah but i want to get like a really
strict routine and get rid of it and
like stick with that and yeah get more
into fitness but i'm putting it off you
know it's that's just i'm making excuses
yeah because i could start that today
yeah yeah macy
my answer was so much different than
yours uh i don't think i deserve
anything good that's happened in my life
to be honest with you guys and i'm
worried uh that i'm very insecure at
some point it's just all gonna fall
apart and everyone's gonna realize like
how undeserving i am of it
so it's imposter syndrome right is that
what it's called
yeah i mean that's a that's yeah
probably imposter syndrome with with
self it's just general self-esteem
probably a mix of it but i think i hate
myself no but but feeling like myself
but feeling undeserving of it like you
you're not deserving of these things
that you have i personally felt imposter
syndrome for sure
uh in the beginning of the work that i
was doing with graham i was like what
led for graham to pick my email what led
for
me to be able to do this work for him
what led for all of this stuff and
after i
associate with a lot of other people
that like would be conventionally deemed
as successful you understand that
like most of them they benefited because
of connection that they
they made and you know what i mean like
it's very rare that someone just comes
up independently you know what i mean
and also another thing is
it's hard to feel good about yourself
when you're surrounded by people that
are
like amazing and we're very fortunate to
be around people that like are
conventionally deemed as successful
and when you see that all the time it's
like you compare yourself to them and i
think that's just an unhealthy thing and
i've worked on it and i don't have
imposter syndrome anymore
uh and i don't know yeah i would agree
with that and i had the same experience
as jack where i was like well how did i
i get here um and in the beginning i was
like i don't know i just
randomly picked my video um but then the
longer that i thought about it um i i
think about like oh well i was putting
work into
doing tick tocks and stuff and because i
was making tick tocks i made youtube
videos because i made youtube videos i
had
a video set up uh already going like i
had my lights set up and everything and
um it helped me be like one of the first
people out there and you know it goes on
and goes on um and you have to also
think about it like if you hadn't put in
the work to upload as much as you do on
that youtube channel you wouldn't have
the subscribers that you do uh because
otherwise you know
i would just have 50 uh how many do you
have me see how many subscribers 53 000
yeah otherwise why wouldn't people go
subscribe to me
on alexander nava on youtube no i'm just
kidding but uh you know it's really the
work that you put in um and obviously
doing grim helps but
because if you don't put in any of the
work you're not gonna get there everyone
knows someone graham knew jason you know
when he created that other brokerage you
just so happen to be placed in a in a
location that is very near a place that
sells a really expensive real estate you
know
a bunch of just things happen by chance
but it's your choice to you know
capitalize on those opportunities alex
your turn
um well have i said my weight in the
past yes
um all right well you got a few options
you got physical or you got the deep
yeah it's emotional
it's interesting how i'm almost gonna
cry i feel like yeah guys went for the
physical
and i feel like if you didn't bring that
up to alex you his was also gonna be
physical uh let's all i would love to to
s
switch the roles and then you say
something emotional oh but let's let's
have alex let's get alex go first um
okay i'm trying to think i i was
preparing for my weight but i guess i
can't use that so um
no you can use that i mean if there's
truly
i'll do a new physical one all right let
me you want me to do another physical
one
okay because my i only have other than
my weight i only have one physical like
thing that i'm insecure about and i
don't mind sharing it um i'm missing a
toenail on my big toe
and uh so some when i go to the beach
and like i'm like oh i have to take off
my socks and it feels weird um and uh
the story behind that is my friend in
high school kicked my toe like on out as
a joke and i guess she hit the right
angle and it went sideways and
i had to get it removed so yeah
all right i think we're good yeah cool
cool all right well macy thank you so
much for coming on we'll link to your
info down below in the description uh
the same place by the way that you can
get a free stock that you can send to
the patreon oh yeah our page we to talk
about that we got to give shout outs to
the patreon members
questions
oh let's just realize that yeah we're
going to be spending a lot of that money
back on um setting up the event of a
lifetime we're going to do two events a
year so basically whatever you spend on
that goes towards these events and we'll
we'll do something fun depending on the
size of the group if it's two people
it's it's gonna be way more intimate um
and maybe we do something a little bit
like i don't know we'll figure something
out we could rent out a bowling alley
topgolf and you know be funny jack if we
get everyone um chips to go gamble out
at the casino
and we say like hey we're gonna be doing
topgolf we got a a private driver alex
you could drive us a private driver down
to uh yellowtail and then everyone has
hundred dollars to go and we could like
uh put it on the table that would be fun
i actually really like that yeah and
they could keep and they could keep
whatever they win yeah but they have to
gamble they have to gamble it but they
could keep the winnings and maybe they
could yeah that would be red rock would
probably let you guys do that yeah you
had like your own blackjack table or
something that's true that'd be fun yeah
we want to make the event really cool
yeah it's gonna be sweet so maton asks
uh it was cool seeing you at the creator
clash should jack box at the second
event so i know macy's trying to box at
the second event
she really wants to she's made a video
on it i would probably be down to box at
the second event but i just don't think
i really want to commit myself to
something else that's like so exhausting
time intensive and whatnot so i get that
yeah i think you would do well but you
would have to dedicate every day i'd say
an hour a day real estate if i got in
the ring i would not lose that's all i'm
going to say and i would you know
anything it depends where you're who
you're fighting to
graham
i wouldn't lose that's what everybody
says jack everybody's like if that were
me i wouldn't lose well guess what one
person out of the two has to lose that's
true right you know i could be a draw
maybe i would i recognize there's a
chance if i do this i could lose i just
like as long as i can get in quite a few
good punches i'm okay you're happy
because like some especially with like
people that are amateurs that this all
it takes is like one good punch and you
have a concussion because you don't know
how to block very well it's not instinct
to know how to block at that point so
i'm like as long as i get in a few good
ones you just see like spit flying out
of their face yeah i'm good
what's the next question the next one is
uh why patreon now whose idea was it the
main idea was the fact that we really
want to take this podcast to the next
level and we felt like patreon would be
a good way to get us there and also the
event thing sounds super fun to be able
to like meet up with you guys put out a
bunch of money for a fancy dinner and
maybe gambling or whatever that also
sounds fun and i don't just sound like
so it was your idea though no no it
wasn't it's your idea it was your idea
what i thought was your idea i kept
telling you that you needed to start a
patreon what i thought amazing i kept
telling you okay spacey's idea basically
came up with it but it's also a good way
for us to get up the podcast early
take questions like do all these other
things you were saying no and i said you
guys should do longer forms of them just
like how logan paul has that exclusive
end bit where they're answering
questions yeah it was adam 22. was it
that oh you know why because he's
monetizing in all these other like right
yeah
and we're like oh patreon sounds pretty
sweet we can offer bonus content and a
bunch of other really cool that was it
yeah all right well let's i think we're
good
all right thank you guys so much for
watching also i know they're not
sponsoring this video guys but big shout
out to ftx they've been supporting us on
this podcast the entire the entire time
so we're going to leave a link down
below if you guys want to help out the
podcast and or use an amazing exchange
that charges zero fees with these
they're up to 85 percent lower than the
top company yeah you may have no gas
fees for them through people like steph
curry tom brady or the coachella
miami
check them out down below in the
description thank you guys so much for
watching and
add me on instagram until next time